[Music]
hi everybody we're here for the Thursday
night class
my master choice and till we're gonna go
over one of my games actually played
here at the Chess Club because in 17 as
you can tell from my a lot of my video
lessons that you know most of the time I
just play here so pretty much all the
games that played right here in this
beautiful chess club st. Louis so this
is the game actually against Grandmaster
barish Pollock and the really nice
tournament for me I won this tournament
it was st. Louis Spring Classic
Tournament after a year that they
started in the classics 2017 and this
was a Pendleton all around so I played
d4 so my opponents about 2600 rated
Grandmaster from Ukraine but he is a
student at the Texas Tech University
here so Knight f6 c4 g6 so again we
don't know the name of the opening yet
okay it could be a groom felt or it
could be a Kings Indian defense so we
don't know the opening yet we have to
wait for the last month Knight c3 Bishop
g7 now once it once body spa let's play
Bishop g7 now we know the opening it's a
Kings Indian defense Knight f3 d6 d4
castles h3
age three idea is to control the G for
square ctrl G for square and to prevent
Bishop g4 or ninety four ideas now my
opponent played Knight a six ish the
idea behind this move is to prepare a
five and that the right woman being
being able to put a knight on c5 so I
could be stupidly developing my Bishop I
was expecting something like if I were
to 86 now he changed he changed the play
a little bit he played c6 now he wants
to play d5 he wants to push he wants to
push d5 now I played a tree idea behind
a tree is to prevent a knight from
coming to before and get some more
control here and I was expecting the
move d5 so now I want to pause here and
give you some time to think for our for
our audience here at the club and also
people watching on our YouTube channel
we have a lot of people watching us so
let's pause here for a minute or two and
try to understand what should white do
here in this position white black just
play d5 is questioning the center but
what should we do in this position so we
have some options okay we have some
options here definitely but what can we
do here
yes
sorry well if you do it then he's gonna
go 94 yeah he's gonna go 94
well maybe take
okay ticks
and now I need you to think of getting
space c5 take XC 5
yeah wow this is the game yeah that's
why I played a tree because now I can
always support before I have the c4
support option so it was Knight e4 well
that's why I play the 83 here when he
played c6 I already knew that he's
planning to play d5 here I knew that's
what he wants to do so that's why I
played the move a tree now he goes d5
take take
see five and now I can play before here
now I would like to play before now it
was 94 activating the night
now activating tonight and obviously
black night should be on c6 here then
he's absolutely fine by the night 186 is
a little bit miss place okay
now what can you do yeah and play b6
yeah he's looking to take my night and
play b6 well you could go Queen c2 that
is a possibility what else what else you
think you have
to see one
you could go Roxy won but I took on a
six because that way look I'm developing
I know it's like you don't want to give
up the bishop because a little bit more
valuable but here I'm damaging the
structure and getting castle okay
night eggs
take
and it takes this is very interesting
now he has weak pants on a father and I
have a strong past pawn here on c5 okay
but the neck form is very important
white to play here you don't want to
rush I know you're thinking about
Catholic you know you could do that but
you know you don't want to rush with it
there is no immediate danger here yet is
there anything else you can think of
here
well rupee won but then you're going to
run into bishop at five
so let's see the white with the white
goal is to push that pawn eventually
well well he wants to go rook b8 and get
the rook into the game like that Oh
castle f6 and now he wants to play e5
what can you do
of course not Bishop f4 now we
controlling it
so I actually thought I played this
before first I could have played Bishop
f4 here first as well but so it was this
move order now he goes here g5 attacking
the bishop bishop g3 goes h5
you could but I think I liked you treat
a little bit better because I had some
h4 ideas here
now if they'd aged five he's trying to
get a counter play so he's trying to
push his pants and look for some
possible counter play now
yep
Knight II one now my idea is to put the
knight on d3 from d3 I can also go to f4
you tree to afford to put pressure now I
go sir
93 now I want to go to F for mangoes
Queen d7
I mean if takes Queen D 3 a 6 is hanging
and a lot of weaknesses so that's why
either one that save the Queen d7
yes
well I could play night afore I just
want to get a look into the game because
it's an open file you know 94 is good to
90 we should before now he goes Bishop
before rook takes e4 okay this was not
sure it was completely necessary but I
think it's very interesting sacrifice so
we take he takes and Knight f4 now we
attacking to h5 and also threaten Queen
b3 check putting the night on this is my
goal is to try to push the C pawn but it
plays correctly v I take on h5 Bishop h8
if I could win the g7 pawn with my two
connected past on C and D I should be in
really good shape here but us Bishop
here now it gets it gets a little
complicated okay so I don't know if
maybe this rookie 4 was the cleanest I'm
not sure now what can you do
I see
well G for Queen takes it
he distract his plane somewhere else
yes
Brian and Jim Sadie five well the
problem with d5 is my knight and my
bishops are out of place if it's a
playable move it's nothing wrong with it
but I'm worried he's gonna start pushing
f5a for and getting counter play so my
goal is to get my knight into the game
as soon as possible so that's why I go
bish page two to go Knight g3 now he
goes here now what do you do we need to
attacking the e4 pawn now he takes we
take if he thinks g4 pawn is hanging
that's huge guys
g4 pawn is on three so it plays f5 now
he wants to take the pawn on d4 what are
we gonna do Bishop d6 cementing it
because now if he takes there's a Quincy
forecheck winning the bishop so by
placing the bishop on d6 is a monster of
square attacking the rook and stopping
his ideas so he goes Queen f7 he is
willing to give up the rook
I don't want it yet I will here he goes
jittery trying to complicate matters
Queen III control control the position
takes King takes very strong night I
have strong plans but still bit messy
here not so simple now I go screen f6
hitting on h d4 and hitting on H for
hitting simultaneously what should I do
now
what should I do in this position
well but my g3 pawn is hanging you know
so h4 pun is hanging if I do that
look on each one you can but then you're
dropping the d4 pawn to Queen takes d4
kappa taking a look first it's a
valuable piece we take it huh
now he takes now he's attacking the rook
as well
no we need a good move here if you take
he's gonna take back with the bishop
check and is gonna take the rook on a
one rook e1 correct protecting
everything okay
Tex
see six parts pounds they meant to be
pushed and here this pawn is under
attack there is some potential for him
to check and take so that's why you want
to push it okay now it goes Queen d6
Queen b3 check Queen b3 check checking
that King now he goes here look f7
what we ate he'll take you don't rush
don't rush see important not to rush now
what's a goalless one would be a good
move here
now what can you do here
a four-night needs to be protected but
maybe instead of protecting it we can do
something else now instead of just
protecting it and trying to protect
a ditch
we have twin texts night I know but your
night is hanging he can take with the
check so I don't know if you really want
to do that yes you could do a Quinjet
view what else what else do you have
here
you do have Queen g3 but you have
something else can you can you move this
night somewhere with some potential pins
and attacks on this
perfect
now 1395 check
well you could take but I just looking
at you now I'm threatening a very strong
95-98 attacking and forking that's why
so he cannot take so he goes Bishop e6
and now what is the idea
what is the idea
what is the idea yes what about the peen
yeah you have here the pinning now the
only way for him not to lose a rope he
has to go check but luckily this is just
winning because I'm up upon I still have
the c6 pawn so he goes here now
because Hicks can g7
and don't rush it's still not too late
to make a bad move and spoil the
position okay but you don't want to
spoil it
yeah like to plan win
that's the winner because now if he
takes I have rook check and I take the
bishop if he takes I go 96 check and I
Quinn so his only move is to go here and
now you have a chance you have
opportunity to finish this game in a
beautiful style can you do that can you
finish the game in a beautiful style Ben
Bravo Ben rook takes b6 now threatened
Group B he resigned here because if he
captures go check take the rope and and
that's how this 2600 grand master
resigned got it yes yes yes this is my
game against our master buddish bullets
so I push if it takes again we have
rookie 7 Roxy 7 so it has to go to f8 ok
if it goes to FA then you just take on B
6 + 96 check got it very good any quick
yeah absolutely absolutely
okay so that was the game you understand
the opening part the Kings Indian with
h3 okay so really quickly let's go over
the opening part so you can see it got
really messy at some point it probably
probably should have now down there but
see this is a setup d6 and this is a
good setup for block because this kind
of stops the Bishop g5 idea because a
Bishop g5 you can play h-65 here because
he is still on Castle say Castle h3 96
Bishop e3 c6 because now he is put into
play d5 and I think I think this move is
very important here I think this is a
very very important move here a3
yeah yeah exactly exactly well he also
doesn't if he plays ePHI he's worried me
playing the fire so that's what he wants
to put this is not a very typical setup
this is not a very typical setup but
it's possible okay I took took and
played c5 and now I can play before and
protect the position protect my queen
side advantage 94 I took took yeah and
here's why it is clearly better I mean I
I made it a little bit more complicated
than it should have been I could have
just played Knight f4 Hesh after night
therefore White has a really nice
advantage and it's not that complicated
well he could have gone back on b8 like
here he could have gone back Knight be
it and then go here but I think I'm
doing quite well here there's this
before I think I think like something
like this I take I take white any any
day here because I do have that Queen
side mature majority all right now we're
going to do some positions okay all
right so this is going to be medium
difficulty positions for you to find
okay so let's start out with the first
position
it's white to play and win this is the
endgame this is a very nice endgame idea
that will help you to improve your game
yeah this is from the game
mama dro of Panama roof all right white
to play and win okay that's a mom in the
other ponomaryov Kim okay
now what can you do here
yeah it looks like I mean white maybe a
little bit better but it will be
extremely difficult to win this position
extremely extremely difficult what can
you do
you must be some more thin than
[Music]
well it's it's an idea that you have to
use to win a piece you are actually
winning a piece here so it was a loser
it was a rapid game it was a rapid game
yeah you gotta think you gotta think you
got a definitely think first hmm you got
a think first
maybe's threatening to discover check
and win that Bishop to see how a black
king
but if he moves away from the pot so
what's the move and if I go Bishop d7
nice try but unfortunately it doesn't
quite work if I didn't play that move
yet we would have won the game but
unfortunately I have that move
we go back to this
the next
well if you take the palm here's roof oh
yeah I think he goes King g5 that's
gonna be very hard to win mm-hmm if you
don't get something right away it's very
very challenging to win this even for GM
it's not so easy to see this so once
again this is the gamer a mama D ro
Panama roof from 2016 rapid match okay
yeah I'm forcing moves are checks or
moves that you make that they they force
things okay so what do you see
and I can get away with just pushing the
clock right now this if you take
we should have a chat
so you're thinking about pushing the
pond right takes the bishop what did
monkey discovered attack on
[Music]
what they were discussing but they
didn't follow it true so you guys looked
at d7 right pushing now he takes and
this is a very important idea here you
can do very very important moment
oh then you can take the pond and
that'll be chit yeah but doesn't go back
yeah but you can take on hu you're still
not gonna win this
now what do you do
I don't know if this has been suggested
Bishop a4 with the plan of Bishop a4
check suggested by been check if he
stops away it moves away you're gonna
take the bishop so he has to stay with
it right and now you can pin him and now
the very important thing this Bishop is
doing here guys ah guarding this square
otherwise you would go here and protect
yeah absolutely
strong strong been excellent job yeah
very nice moving forward now everybody
got this so once again to demonstrate we
push we have to push
he takes check and pin and win
flipsie
all right why to play and win from a
game feller bossy bossy Aussies 2016
white to play and win
what to do here white to play and win if
you take now unfortunately you lose your
look and
my first thought was
let him take the road and with the idea
to take this night and let's get that
through
well if you go here here's this angles
here
okay
I just take the pawn and leave the night
on the taxiways got to go didn't the
bank's got that meaning it's places to
get to what's the prize like one two
three four
so black had an extra part anyway
what's the suggestion no.1 if you find
the solution you're gonna win right away
you're gonna see it right away
to be six
yeah but here's 95
this is medium yeah
the chat has come to a consensus
what's the consensus and chart is
correct chart is correct group the four
guys hitting the rook okay now now if he
moves you just take tonight and if it
takes check
now okay he didn't take it moves the
room
they can't move the knife to defend
and now I win a piece and win the game
all right we're gonna do one more guys
the last position okay for this class so
this was very neat rook D formal okay
just move it away attacking the rook and
on f6 let's focus guys let's focus on
this now let's go why to play more cinco
Popples
muy same copepods
Black has two rooks and it looks very
comfortable in this position but white
still has ideas white still has ideas in
this position and he's gonna use this
ideas to win how how can you death
before we meet
Queen
well Queen f4 is an idea something
better something better you need to do
you could but let's look at some
something else some other idea maybe a
break or something aha
look for a brace because you want to
open up the position of opponent's king
okay six right now if he takes what do
you do mate so as you take this way
right now you want to activate your
queen what do you do how you activate
your queen now
25 perfect now 25 is setting up a very
important queen a sick shape winning the
rook and the way the rooks are they are
not connected they were connected that
would have been fine for blood but the
rooks are not connected so that's why
and whatever he does he's gonna lose
this rook because now you're threatening
check and take so for example he goes
here
you go check he takes here you go check
that's why it's very strong okay all
right so that's that's idea for you to
remember so again you have to look when
you have a queen in this kind of
position you have to open up the
position okay so that's why if his rook
was on a better spot then black might be
actually winning if the rook see if this
rook is like on d8 block is winning here
so the fact that rook is misplaced you
go g6 if it takes it's made so it has to
take the other way and now queen is 6
no no matter what he does he is losing
his rook and once he loses the rook he
is very likely to lose the game ok all
right thank you everybody for attending
this class we're gonna take a little
break and get ready for the next class
at around 7:30 ok right
[Music]
you
[Music]